>>> SO, NEGOTIATORS ON CAPITOL
HILL SAY THAT THEY'VE REACHED A
BIPARTISAN FRAMEWORK FOR A
ONE-YEAR SPENDING DEAL, BUT KEY
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP MAY NOT BE
ON THE SAME PAGE HERE.
>> HOUSE GOP LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY SLAMMED SENATE MINORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL FOR
WORKING WITH DEMOCRATS ON THAT
SPENDING DEAL.
CNN'S MELANIE ZANONA JOINS US
FROM CAPITOL HILL NOW.
WE'VE HEARD BEHIND THE SCENES
McCARTHY WAS OPEN, AT LEAST, TO
A LARGE SPENDING DEAL TO WRAP UP
THE YEAR.
WHAT IS HAD HAPPENING HERE
PUBLICLY?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> Reporter: YEAH.
THIS IS THE HOPE YES, VOTE NO
CAUCUS.
MANY REPUBLICANS I TALK TO
BELIEVE THAT McCARTHY IS
PRIVATELY ROOTING FOR THIS
SPENDING BILL TO PASS.
THE REASON IS BECAUSE IF HE DOES
BECOME SPEAKER, THE LAST THING
HE WANTS TO DEAL WITH IS HAVING
TO ADDRESS A POTENTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN UPON
IMMEDIATELY TAKING POWER, BUT AT
THE SAME TIME, HE'S BEEN
STRUGGLING TO WIN OVER SOME OF
HIS CONSERVATIVE CRITICS.
THEY HAVE BEEN PRESSING HIM TO
TAKE A HARDER LINE ON SPENDING
ISSUES, STAND UP TO McCONNELL ON
A NUMBER OF THOSE THINGS AND
THAT IS WHY YOU SEE McCARTHY OUT
THERE PUBLICLY RAILING AGAINST
THIS SPENDING DEAL, AND HE TOOK
A PUBLIC SHOT AT McCONNELL, WHO
HAS BEEN TRYING TO WORK BEHIND
THE SCENES TO GET THIS DEAL
DONE.
SOURCES TELL US THAT McCONNELL
WAS BLINDSIDED BY THAT, AND HE
WAS REALLY CAUGHT OFF GUARD.
NOW, McCARTHY HELD A PRESS
CONFERENCE NOT TOO LONG AGO
WHERE HE, AGAIN, TALKED ABOUT
THIS SPENDING DEAL AND SPOKE OUT
AGAINST IT, AND HE DID NOT
MENTION McCONNELL BY NAME, BUT
HE DID CRITICIZE THE REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRATIC SENATOR WHO
HELPED BROKER THIS DEAL.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I PROPOSE THAT YOU HAVE TWO
SENATORS WHO ARE GONE.
YOU JUST HAD AN ELECTION WHERE
WE CHANGED THE COURSE WHERE THE
HOUSE IS NOW GOING TO BE
CONTROLLED BY REPUBLICANS.
YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS WHO
CONTROLLED ALL AND DIDN'T DO
THEIR JOB IS GOING TO JAM US
RIGHT BEFORE CHRISTMAS A BILL
THAT FUNDING THE ENTIRE
GOVERNMENT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY INPUT IN.
IT WOULDN'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO
WITH BEING SPEAKER, IT HAS TO DO
WITH THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND
WHAT FUTURE OF AMERICA IS GOING
TO BE WHEN IT COMES TO FISCAL
RESOURCES.
>> Reporter: NOW, THE DIVIDE
BETWEEN THE HOUSE GOP AND THE
SENATE GOP IS NOTHING NEW.
IT'S A TALE AS OLD AS TIME.
WE'VE SEEN McCONNELL AND
McCARTHY SPLIT FROM GUNS TO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IF KEVIN McCARTHY DOES BECOME
SPEAKER THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
INTERESTING DYNAMIC TO WATCH,
GUYS.
>> SO POLITICS AS USUAL AT PLAY
HERE.
THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING US NOW IS POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR ALYSSA FARAH GRIFFIN
A FORMER WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE STRATEGY
OF KEVIN McCARTHY?
SURELY HE DOES NOT WANT TO
INHERIT A MAJORITY AND
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN AT THE SAME
TIME?
>> RIGHT.
THAT'S WHERE MELANIE NAILED IT.
IT WOULDN'T BE THE HOLIDAYS IF
CAPITOL HILL WASN'T SCRAMBLING
TO AVERT A GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
WE'RE USED TO THIS EVERY
DECEMBER.
BUT THIS IS VERY MUCH KEVIN
McCARTHY PUBLICLY SAYING
SOMETHING THAT IS PRIVATELY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT HE WANTS TO
SEE HAPPEN.
WHAT'S GOING TO BE INTERESTING
TO GET THIS ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME
MODERATE REPUBLICANS, IF HE'S
SMART -- AND HE IS, KEVIN IS A
STRATEGICALLY WISE PERSON --
THOSE ARE GOING TO BE THE MOST
IMPORTANT PEOPLE TO HIM IF HE
BECOMES SPEAKER, THE MODERATE
REPUBLICANS WILLING TO CROSS
OVER THE AISLE.
THERE'S BIG PRIORITIES THAT COME
UP NEXT CYCLE, THE NATIONAL
DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION, FARM BILL
REAUTHORIZATION, THINGS HE'S NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO PASS ON HIS
SLIM REPUBLICAN MAJORITY, SO
THIS IS A MOMENT WHERE HE'S
SAYING, PLEASE VOTE FOR THIS TO
A NUMBER OF MODERATE REPUBLICANS
WHILE PUBLICLY BLASTING IT.
>> THAT'S FOR THE CONSUMPTION OF
THE REST OF THE CONFERENCE, HE'S
TRYING TO GET TO 218 TO GET THE
GAVEL?
>> THE MAGIC NUMBER.
>> PELOSI HAD SOME HOLDOUTS IN
2019.
BOEHNER HAD HOLDOUTS IN 2013
ALMOST WENT TO A SECOND BALLOT
FOR THE SPEAKER'S RACE.
WHAT IS McCARTHY FACING THEY DID
NOT FACE THAT HE COULD
POTENTIALLY GO ROUND AFTER ROUND
IN SEARCH OF THE VOTES TO GET
THERE?
>> THIS IS COMING FROM THE
VINTAGE FREEDOM CAUCUS PLAUB
THEY TRIED TO RUN AGAINST JOHN
BOEHNER AND SPEAKER RYAN BACK IN
2015.
KEEP IN MIND, THEY ONCE BLOCKED
KEVIN McCARTHY FROM BEING
SPEAKER BEFORE AND EVENTUALLY
PAUL RYAN STEPPED UP AND PUT HIS
NAME FORWARD.
THE SAME GROUP, WHICH LOOKS
DIFFERENT NOW, DIFFERENT MEMBERS
ARE SAYING WE HAVE FOUR STRONG
HOLDOUTS, BUT 31 VOTED AGAINST
HIM IN THE PRIVATE CAUCUS
MEETING.
MY GUESS KEVIN IS DOING WHATEVER
HE CAN TO TWIST TWO OF THOSE
ARMS TO GET HIM TO THE NUMBER HE
NEEDS TO BE AT.
THAT'S A TOUGH THING TO DO AND
THEY'VE BEEN VERY PUBLIC AND
OUTSPOKEN I THINK OF MATT GAETZ
AND OTHERS I'M NOT SURE YOU
COULD SWITCH THEIR VOTES.
DURING THE FLOOR VOTE THEY WOULD
VOTE FOR SOMEONE ELSE, ANDY
BIGGS, AND IT COULD GO TO
MULTIPLE BALLOTS.
THE ASSUMPTION SOMEONE WILL
EMERGE AS A CANDIDATE, JIM
JORDAN, IS IT --
>> SCALISE PERHAPS.
>> MORE ALIGNED WITH THE
CONSERVATIVE FLANK WITHIN THE
HOUSE.
THE BEST ARGUMENT KEVIN McCARTHY
HAS IS THAT THEY HAVE NOT PUT UP
A VIABLE ALTERNATIVE THEMSELVES
WHO CAN GET TO 218, AND HE HAS
DONE A MAST AREFUL JOB AT
WRANGLING THE ARMS OF HIS RANK
AND FILE AND GETTING MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE IN HIS CORNER.
WE'LL SEE.
IT'S AN OPEN QUESTION IF HE WILL
GET THE SPEAKERSHIP.
>> WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU THAT
EVEN THE FORMER PRESIDENT
ADVOCATING FOR HIM TO GET THE
SPEAKERSHIP ROLE AND VOUCHING
FOR HIM PUBLICLY IS NOT GETTING
HIM TO THAT PLACE RIGHT NOW?
>> I THINK IT SHOWS TRUMP'S
WEAKENED STATE WITHIN THE PARTY.
PREMIDTERMS THAT WAS PRETTY MUCH
McCARTHY WAS BANKING ON IF HE
HAD THE TRUMP ENDORSEMENT HE
WOULD GET OVER THE FINISH LINE.
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT TAKING BACK
THE SENATE AND HAVING A MAJORITY
IN THE HOUSE, I THINK THAT THE
POWER THAT TRUMP HAS EVEN WITHIN
THE CONFERENCE ITSELF AND THE
HOUSE REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE IS
CERTAINLY MORE CONSERVATIVE THAN
THE SENATE, HIS VOICE JUST
DOESN'T MATTER THE WAY THAT IT
ONCE DID.
FRANKLY I WOULD BE CALLING RON
DeSANTIS AND ASKING FOR AN
ENDORSEMENT.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT RON
DeSANTIS, THERE'S NEW POLLING
OUT, WARM OFF THE PRINTER SO
FRESH, 62% OF REPUBLICANS AND
REPUBLICAN LEANING INDEPENDENTS
WANT SOMEONE OTHER THAN DONALD
TRUMP AT THE TOP OF THE TICKET
IN 2024.
MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO WANT
SOMEONE ELSE WANT RON DeSANTIS,
FLORIDA GOVERNOR.
NO ONE ELSE HAS MORE THAN A
SINGLE PERCENTAGE POINT IN THIS.
IF YOU ARE A TED CRUZ, IF YOU'RE
A NIKKI HALEY, DOES THIS MATTER
SO FAR OUT FROM IOWA?
WHAT DO YOU SEE HERE?
>> WELL, DeSANTIS IS THE
CONSUMMATE FRONTRUNNER RIGHT NOW
AFTER HAVING VICTORY, WHAT WE
WOULD CALL VICTORY DURING THE
MIDTERMS WHEN OTHER REPUBLICANS
JUST DID NOT DO AS WELL AS WE
ANTICIPATED.
MY CAUTION WITH THE DeSANTIS
MOMENTUM HE'S PEAKING EARLY.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
COME AT HIM MUCH HARDER, JUST BY
NATURE WHAT TRUMP IS GOING TO
DO, BUT THIS IS HIS BIGGEST
RIVAL RIGHT NOW.
I THINK ALL OF THAT ENERGY IS
GOING TO COME ON TRYING TO
ATTACK RON DeSANTIS WHICH COULD
OPEN THE FIELD TO OTHER
CANDIDATES.
I WOULD KEEP MY EYES ON SOME
GOVERNORS, PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF
FORMER TRUMP CABINET SECRETARIES
WHO MAY BE THINKING SEEING THE
MIDTERMS, HEY, THIS MIGHT BE AN
OPENING FOR ME TO RUN, WHETHER
ASA HUTCHINSON OR CHRIS SUNUNU
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
I THINK THEY HAVE A GOOD CASE TO
MAKE FOR JUST KIND OF A CHANGE.
WE'VE RUN A STATE AND DONE IT
EFFECTIVELY AND KIND OF PUTTING
THIS TRUMP ERA BEHIND US.
THAT COULD BE FORMIDAB